leben wir in einer matrix sind wir nur
projektionen
es gibt hinweise darauf dass genau das
der fall sein könnte
ich bin christoph krachten und das hier
ist die kicks um science fiction die
idee eines holografischen universums
also dass wir wie in einem 3d
filmprojekt irrt werden ist womöglich
keine spinnerei wie in der matrix wie in
dem film existieren wir dann nicht hier
sondern woanders aber wo kann das ein
hirngespinst sein
die neuesten wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse sprechen dafür dass es
vielleicht der fall sein könnte
angefangen hat alles mit einer wette des
wohl berühmtesten noch lebenden physiker
stephen hawking
er hatte gewettet dass ein schwarzes
loch seine in ihm enthaltenen
informationen nicht mehr heraus gibt das
heißt dass alles was das schwarze loch
an informationen über die beschaffenheit
der in ihm enthaltenen materie weiß dass
das verschwindet aber genau das ist
nicht der fall
der kasus knaxus ist der
ereignishorizont des schwarzen loches
das ist die grenze oder gülle des
schwarzen loches der sogenannte
ereignishorizont alles jenseits dieser
grenze wird vom schwarzen loch
aufgesogen und verschluckt und außerhalb
dieser grenze gibt es noch eine chance
den schwarzen noch zu entkommen
und an dieser grenze am ereignishorizont
da gibt es eine schwache strahlung die
das schwarze loch abstrahlt die
sogenannte open strahlung und diese
strahlung gibt es so lange bis das loch
all seine masse verloren hat und wieder
verschwindet der israelische physiker
jacob eggenstein konnte nachweisen dass
diese strahlung alle informationen des
schwarzen loches enthält stephen hawking
hatte seine wette verloren
es gilt also folgendes erstens die
strahlung die vom schwarzen loch ausgeht
enthält
alle informationen zweitens diese
strahlung geht vom ereignishorizont aus
das heißt die informationen sind in der
hülle des schwarzen loches im
ereignishorizont enthalten aber warum
sollte diese idee auf unser universum zu
treffen dass es erstmal bloßen annahme
eben eine idee kann sein muss nicht sein
allerdings hat unser universum merkmale
eines schwarzen loches es gibt zum
beispiel eine hülle einen ereignis
horizont hinter dem wehr nicht sehen
können was bedeutet das also für die
idee dass unser universum eine 3d
projektion ist im universum selbst
existiert nicht sondern alles spielt
sich tatsächlich auf der hülle ab alles
existiert auf der hülle und wird zum
beispiel hier auf die erde projiziert
doch wie finden wir heraus ob das
tatsächlich der fall ist
viele behaupten ja dass ein déjà vu ein
zeichen dafür ist dass es einen fehler
in der matrix gibt ein fehler im ablauf
der ereignisse zweimal stattfinden lässt
aber auch die wissenschaft hat einen
hinweis entdeckt beim gravitations
detector geo600 bei hannover wurde ein
indiz entdeckt der amerikanische
astrophysiker craig hogan
er hat überlegt was für konsequenzen ein
holografische universum für die
kleinsten im universum bekannten
strukturen hätte die quanten sie sind
zehn hoch minus 33 cm groß das ist ein
millionstel grads 3 zentimeter mini mini
mini klein nicht messbar
und wenn wir jetzt eine projektion
werden wären sie ja auch eine projektion
und da auf der hülle oder da im raum
immer mehr platz ist als auf der ihn
umgebenden hülle müssten die
projizierten teilchen deutlich größer
sein
auf die oberfläche dieses balles zum
beispiel verpassen
23 a 4 blätter und
während dieser vier blätter jetzt eine
projektion in den ball und müssen dort
den ganzen raum im ball ausfüllen
müssten sie viel viel größer sein um
wirklich das volumen auszufüllen
also müssten die kleinstmöglichen
strukturen wenn sie von der hülle hier
ins innere projiziert werden hier im
inneren er deutlich größer sein craig
hogan hat auch ausgerechnet wie groß 10
hoch minus 16 zentimeter das ist also
wirklich um das x-fache größer da sind
eben mal 17 00 hinterm komma abhanden
gekommen er wandte sich dann an die
kollegen von gravitationswellen detector
geo600 bei hannover sie messen dort die
krümmung der raumzeit durch masse
sie müssen in ihren messungen dann diese
vergrößerten raum quanten feststellen
können
als freak hogan mit den kollegen kontakt
aufnahmen war die verblüffung dann groß
denn es gab bereits hinweise auf diese
vergrößerten raum quanten sie hatten in
ihren messungen ein mysteriös rauschen
festgestellt man kann sich das
tatsächlich wie die matrix animation
vorstellen also ein grundrauschen das
unsere matrix bildet und was die
wissenschaftler dort in hannover keinem
bekannten physikalischen phänomen
zuordnen konnten der verdacht liegt also
nahe dass es sich tatsächlich bei diesem
rauschen um die vergrößerten raum
quanten handelt und wird in zukunft am
geo600 detaillierter gemessen könnte
sich also schon bald herausstellen dass
wir lediglich projektionen sind und in
einer matrix leben was meint ihr habt
ihr schon irgendwas erlebt was für die
matrix spricht telepathie wird zb so ein
phänomen was durch die matrix erklärbar
wäre wie er lebt ihr déjà vu
ich bin auf eure erfahrungsberichte in
den kommentaren gespannt mehr über
schwarze löcher gibt es übrigens hier
und wenn ihr mehr über cannabis wissen
wollt dann klickt da und wenn ihr nicht
verpassen wollt dann solltet ihr ein abo
da lassen das geht hier unten und an
sonst würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran